[Music]
in our newest original we are pleased to
present you once again a movie from the
dceu shazam fury of the gods almost
three years have passed since the
release of the first part and slowly but
surely fans are looking for a follow-up
from billy batson and the like you will
not have to wait too much longer for the
theatrical releases it is scheduled for
this coming december which is why we
highly recommend this latest movie
preview of shazam fury of the gods find
out everything you need to know about
the plot the cast and the production
first of all let's recap the events of
shazam from 2019 for a brief moment the
plot revolves around billy batson a 14
year old teenager who's looking for his
parents after his stay in a children's
home he's taken in by the vasquez family
and is introduced to his new siblings
eugene darla pedro mary and freddie
billy quickly becomes friends with
freddie in particular at one point he
comes into contact with the wizard
shazam who chooses billy as his new
champion after many unworthy candidates
this comes with the fact that billy can
transform himself into the mighty hero
shazam at any time by uttering his name
with his friend freddy he soon finds out
the full extent of his new abilities
these include for example superhuman
speed and strength resistance to bullets
and fire and the ability to fly actually
shazam is an acronym as all the letters
of the word stand for the initial
letters of six deities each of which
lend him a different skill solomon
hercules atlas zeus achilles and mercury
billy has lots of fun with his new super
powers however being a superhero is not
only about fun and games but also about
fighting evil in shazam the evil also
has a name and that happens to be doctor
this savannah the latter was rejected by
the wizard and instead holds the power
of the seven deadly sins the scientist
also has it in for shazam because he too
wants to acquire superpower the
situation does continues to worsen and
finally dr savannah has no qualms about
dragging billy's new family into it at
the end of the movie dr savannah and his
henchmen are defeated by shazam and the
marvel family which leaves room for a
new villain now that you can roughly
remember the events of the first part it
is time to talk about the plot of shazam
fury of the gods in fact the people in
charge are still being extremely vague
when it comes to the plot but that won't
stop us from giving you the best
theories about what will happen in
shazam fury of the gods
first of all let's clarify the question
who will be considered for the role of
the new antagonist it is pretty much
clear that the main villain will be none
other than mr mind this was not only
evident from a mid-credits scene of
shazam but also from the comics where he
has been known since the 1940s
originally he's just a two-inch alien
warm endowed with superhuman
intelligence in sad scene we hear and
see him making contact with savannah in
a jail cell mr mind reveals that he
names the gods and not the other way
around and that he also looks forward to
the fun the two will have together in
addition the super villain is the
founder of the monster society of evil
in the comics a group of over 40 of
captain marvel's worst enemies as named
by shazam of the comics among them are
doctors savannah and other creatures
like mr adam or king khal most
interestingly real people also play a
role in the comics as adolf hitler and
benito mussolini are also part of the
monster society of evil and were subject
to mr mind's command this by the way
also extends to deep mental levels since
in the comics mr mind also has mastered
the art of telepathy incidentally before
the crisis on infinite earth's comics
from 1985 in 1986 he only mastered this
by making physical contact with his
victim after that mr mind existed in a
slightly modified version most recently
he was also introduced into the current
dc rebirth reality of dc comics in this
third version of mr mine he's no longer
a child of the planet venus but a
magical being trapped in a bottle by the
circle of eternity the alien origin has
been completely dropped and instead the
circle of eternity concludes that mr
mind was once a bookworm who got his
supernatural abilities by eating magical
scrawls how exactly mr mind will appear
in shazam fury of the gods is not clear
but we are very excited about the new
super villain who is considered one of
the most powerful in the entire dc
universe another good hint of the plot
is the official title of the sequel
shazam fury of the gods in fact it is
not yet officially known who is meant by
the aforementioned gods fans widely
agree that a god on the side of the bad
guys might be a bit too mighty for
shazam who gets the superpowers from
numerous gods himself however since the
title fury of the gods refers to a
certain anger of the deities it could
also be that they are mad at shazam and
want to take away his powers for that to
happen however they would first have to
return from the dead since the gods in
question died a long time ago
nevertheless it cannot be ruled out that
the sequel will close a gap at this
point which would allow the powerful
deities to return a multiverse storyline
for shazam fury of the gods is likewise
conceivable already in the first part
the rock of eternity plays a big role
and it offers more than enough
possibilities to include the multiverse
the rock was originally the home of the
wizard shazam and is the source of magic
itself it is located in the middle of
the multiverse and is a mysterious place
in shazam we see billy and his alter ego
try to escape from the rock and end up
in a room with countless doors to other
dimensions the room for exploration is
of course huge after all all existing dc
universes are theoretically open to the
protagonist yet the big multiverse bang
is presumably going to come with the
upcoming the flash its release date is
set for june 23 2023 which is after
shazam 2.
moving on to the cast of shazam fury of
the gods coming back are the two main
actors zachary levi as shazam and asher
angel as the slightly older billy batson
plans are also being made to have
billy's foster family return in both old
and new form meaning both siblings and
parents as well as the adult hero
versions of the kids incidentally
director david f sandberg also posted
this setup in june 2021 preempting any
leaks and posting a picture of the
aforementioned characters himself
including their superhero outfits on
twitter in addition to levi and the
angel sure to join the cast are jack
dylan grazer as freddy jimon hansu as
wizard shazam helen mirren as espera
lucy lou as calypso and rachel zegler as
the still unknown daughter of atlas
the plot of shazam fury of the gods was
already put on paper by henry gayden
shortly after the success of the first
part it was also quickly clear that both
director david f sandberg and lead actor
zachary levi would return after
postponement due to the pandemic
pre-production began the summer of 2020
although the first take was not shot
until may 2021 filming then lasted until
august 2021 and december 21 2022 release
was realistically promised in the
process the theatrical release was
pushed forward by 5 days to avoid direct
competition with disney's avatar 2 the
way of water
at cinemacon at the end of april there
was new footage of shazam fury of the
gods on display according to eyewitness
reports the new teaser shows the
protagonist shazam on a date with wonder
woman in paris at least that's what
we're supposed to think at first glance
in fact it is not an appearance of gal
gadot as wonder woman but an illusion of
the wizard who has invaded billy's
dreams in order to warn him he is being
pursued by the daughters of atlas whose
first letter also stands for the a in
shazam and at least three of the
daughters are antagonists in the
upcoming film they are also said to be
seen in a fight with shazam and the
teaser at the end billy superpowered
siblings from the first part of the
scene rushing to his aid so we can
expect some action we are excited
what do you guys think about our
theories on chez and fury of the gods
and which dc characters can you still
imagine appearing in the franchise and
what do you even think of the prequel
feel free to let us know in the comments
by december 21st 2022 at the latest we
will know exactly what to expect in the
dc sequel see you next time
[Music]